Definitely this one. The trend is downward sloping. So it can't be any of these
positive slopes and it definitely doesn't look like the data go through this
value up here or here. And this one looks like it slopes downward too steeply.
We can see which one is better, but how do we determine mathematically which is
the best. For example, how do we know that this line, in blue, isn't slightly
better? There are a lot of lines that could look like they best approximate the
data. So we have to mathematically find the exact a and b, the y intercept and
slope that will get us the line of best fit. How do we find these regression
coefficients? Let's look at these examples again. Remember how we talked about
observed and expected values? Let's say we're deciding whether this would be a
good regression line. For this x value. The expected value is way down here.
For this x value, the expected value is also pretty far. This x value looks to
be pretty close to the expected value but these two are really far from their
expected values. The same with this. The expected value for this value of x. Is
way up here. So this residual actually isn't too bad. But the amount of the
residual gets worse and worse as we continue. Same with this one. If we
continued this line really far out, the residual for this data value would be
huge. All of them would be pretty big. And these would be really big. But here,
the residuals are pretty small, especially compared to the other possibilities.
For these two points the residuals are about zero.